getting jinx away from me he's the
pocket rocket from Pontefract who became
a rugby league legend
[Applause]
at 5:45 critics told Rob burrow he'd
never make it
he went on to star for Leeds Rhinos
England and Great Britain for gistic all
Christmas the 37 year old received a
devastating diagnosis of motor neuron
disease motor neuron disease affects
nerves in the brain and spinal cord
muscles to generate it is fatal
I don't want pity I don't want you know
people feel sorry for me as normal
fans and his former club have raised a
quarter of a million pounds to support
Boro his wife and three young children
and there's more to come ground staff
here are getting ready for Sunday's game
between Leeds Rhinos and Bradford Bulls
but Sunday's match is so much more than
just a game of rugby it's a chance for
this club to show its support for one of
its favorite sons a former teammate is
sharing this testimonial match it's a
real easy thing to do to turn my
testimonial gaming through an event that
supports or absolutely do exactly same
for me so it's an honour to have known
him to have played with him the game is
a near sell-out borough plans to play -
for a final few minutes he's confident
that he can get out there catch a ball
Ron make a tackle or two but I think the
wave of emotion just just even speaking
about he just leaves you a little bit
lost for words so I think everybody will
feel that everybody will want to get
behind that will possibly be the last
time borrow plays here a much-loved
player and fighter to the end Katarina
Pataki Sky News in Leeds
[Music]